we've got biological boys playing in
girls Sports it is the women's issue of
our time the claim that banning trans
women from Sports is a feminist issue
number one ignores the history and
diversity of actual feminism feminism
feminism isn't this monolithic movement
it's a compilation or combination of
different perspectives and goals that
aim to achieve what different people see
as gender equality and justice and there
are many feminists who support trans
rights and inclusion and they see trans
women as allies in a struggle against
whatever it is that they believe is the
most important thing to struggle against
and so part of the feminist movement
uh argues that when you exclude trans
women from women's spaces and activities
you're actually reinforcing the very
harmful stereotypes that feminism has
sought to undo